we will now continue with some
announcement relevant to our celebration
last week the students in the 2016 dr.
Martin Luther King jr. I ap design
seminar assembled their installation in
memorial lobby we invite you to view the
exhibit from now until the end of the
day tomorrow in memorial lobby the 2016
all MIT diversity forum is scheduled for
Friday April 29th from 830am 25 30 p.m.
the theme this year is reflect
understand act the keynote speaker will
be Jelani Cobb director of FNS that is
at the University of Connecticut please
save the date and we hope to see you all
at this one or event we will conclude
today's program with the scene of the
lift every voice and saying we ask that
you join in and sing the first verse of
the song the lyrics are located on the
back of your program
you